where are all these serious Democrats
you know who believe in civil liberties
I don't agree with Rand Paul I'm on much
in the world but the fact that it's
someone like him doing it instead of you
know Democrats who spent so much time
under the Bush era condemning these very
same things says a lot about how
bankrupt Congress is on this and other
issues hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV
I'm joined today by Jeremy Scahill he's
the foreign policy correspondent for the
nation and author of a troubling new
book called dirty wars the world is a
battlefield there's also a new IFC
documentary of the same name dirty wars
in which he is sort of the lead
protagonist showing us about how
American foreign policy is being
conducted right now Jeremy thank you
very much great to be with you joining
us right in the book most people know
about the authorization of military
force on September 14th which was signed
into law on September 18th you say there
was another more secretive finding
signed into law on September 17 2001
that is even more momentous tell us
about that right you know I mean Dick
Cheney and Donald Rumsfeld in particular
came into office with an agenda I mean
they of course had no way of knowing
that 9/11 was going to happen but they
really wanted to conduct what Rumsfeld
called a revolution in military affairs
and to transform the way that the US
military operated around the world and
and those guys and also President Obama
have used this the same way sort of saw
the executive branch as operating a
dictatorship when it came to national
security policy
you know Cheney sort of viewed around
Contra not as a scandal but as the model
for how how US foreign policy should be
waged and so when 9/11 happened they
they sort of already had their their
hands on the levers and and started to
issue a series of secret presidential
directives that would authorize the CIA
and u.s. special operations forces to
conduct what are called kinetic
operations either kill or capture
operations in a variety of country
around the world and to have minimal to
no congressional oversight so they
started a program called Greystone which
the abbreviation for it was GST
internally and and that was the umbrella
under which many of what are now viewed
as the more unsavory things that were
done
the bush-era were conducted the black
sites of the CIA were set up the use of
waterboarding and other torture
techniques and the snatching of people
from countries both in declared
battlefields such as Afghanistan or
other countries around the world and
basically they created an archipelago of
black sites interrogation centers and
started to develop alternative legal
reasoning for prosecuting what they
started to call a global war against
terrorism or global war on terror now
part of this was to remove the usual
functions of over said there had been
snatch operations before there had even
been sort of assassination Authority
that was very seldom used yeah so walk
us through what changed from a legal
point of view well you'll remember that
Gerald Ford was the first president to
put on the books a ban or a supposed ban
on assassination and it's not that Ford
was some great opponent of assassination
it's that there was this scandalous
period where the CIA had been involved
with a number of Coos with various
targeted killing operations with
overthrowing democratically elected
government supporting clintus and and
there were a very aggressive
congressional investigations the Church
Committee former Senator Frank church of
Idaho and others aggressively going
after Congress and so Ford coming out of
the Nixon era decided that he was going
to issue an order saying that it's the
policy of the of the United States that
we do not conduct assassinations and
every president since has has updated or
renewed some version of that executive
order Congress has never passed a law
saying that the United States doesn't
assassinate and the reason is Congress
doesn't want to take up that question
every president from Ford to the to the
present has engaged in something that I
think reasonable people could argue is
an assassination President Clinton was
directly targeting Saddam Hussein's
palaces President Reagan attempted to
kill Qadhafi President Bush George W
Bush was involved in all sorts of
targeted killing operations that they
refused to call assassination so you had
this this era preceding 9/11 where every
president sort of found a way around it
Congress didn't want to take off the
question under President Clinton and a
lot of liberals don't like to talk about
this that's when the rendition program
was started Clinton was the it was the
first president to really create a
policy framework for snatching people in
countries and and not sending them to
CIA black sites sending them to Hosni
Mubarak's Egypt or Assad Syria or in
some cases you know Qaddafi's Libya
where people could be interrogated
sometimes with US personnel in the room
and it was a way of saying we're not
doing this but we're facilitating or
aiding other governments in their fight
against terrorism or extremism when when
9/11 happened the CIA then created its
own network of black sites and instead
of sending them exclusively to third
countries the see I started taking
custody of them and interrogating them
on their own so there's been a sort of
continuous arc of US policy toward
escalating the use of assassination
although rebranding and Offutt is
something else and then using secret
prisons either other countries or in the
case of the first six or so years of the
Bush administration actual black sites
run by the CIA now you talk oh there's a
kind of a pivotal moment as we go from
the tradition of let's call it safe
illegal or rare I'm not sure what of the
kind of a snatch program before to this
world that we had since September 11th
it was the case of botched the name
Libby in 2002 tell us about that and how
he was originally treated and then what
happened right I mean you know there's a
book by a former senior FBI interrogator
Ali sufen called the black banners and
Ali Soufan tells the story about how
really early after 9/11 the Clinton
doctrine was still on the books for for
how terrorism was viewed which was
basically a law enforcement approach
terrorism was viewed as a crime the
Clinton folks had created what Richard
Clarke the former senior
counterterrorism adviser called a almost
Talmudic set of qualifications in order
to actually conduct a targeted killing
operation or in order to never do or
never do it which is how it was viewed
in the Special Operations community
remember Rumsfeld and Cheney they viewed
first of all they viewed Clinton as an
almost pacifist character they viewed
the CIA as a liberal debate Society I
mean they wanted to be hitting targets
all the time doing preemptive strikes
against against terrorists so and they
did this I mean they worked in the Ford
administration while he was
of course documents and their view of
executive power was that Congress went
way too far in 1974 the Church
Commission went way too oh yeah and that
has motivated their public line of
course yeah I mean these guys cut their
teeth at a time when when the whole sort
of thing was unraveling under Nixon the
CIA was coming under intense scrutiny
and you had a generation of CIA officers
that had come through the ranks with an
understanding that covert action is
gonna get you hauled in front of the
Senate Intelligence Committee and and
Rumsfeld and Cheney were big fans of
executive orders and using presidential
findings to get around having to go to
Congress they viewed Congress is pretty
much just a funding Oregon and and the
oversight function was only overseeing
how funds were spent but not getting
involved with being briefed on covert
operation and so there was this sort of
fight that happened right after 9/11
between the FBI and the CIA paramilitary
division which was being empowered by
the White House to conduct really
aggressive operations where you would
have actual fights over prisoners that
were taken in Afghanistan or Pakistan in
the early stages and so now Libya was a
guy who was believed to have
intelligence and information about Osama
bin Laden and the al Qaeda Network he's
originally in the custody of the FBI the
FBI agents reported that they were
developing a rapport with him and that
they felt that he was going to be a
cooperating witness that would give them
information and and and just as they
were sort of preparing to take him back
to the United States and bring him into
custody so that they could do thorough
and interrogations and investigation of
him the CIA comes comes through and
takes control of him and they then
remove him to a series of black sites
and torture him and and most of the FBI
people that I talked to at the time and
this has come out and some of their
memoirs say that they believe that
because al Libi was tortured and taken
that the u.s. lost a crucial opportunity
early on to gain actionable intelligence
that could have led to the capture of
many more high-value targets that were
directly involved with the 9/11 attacks
and that sort of set the tone for how
things were going to go and was mental
years it wasn't only that he was
tortured but then he was tortured to
produce a specific result right I mean
these these guys were trying to tie Iraq
to the 9/11 attacks
the CIA because they were under
tremendous pressure from Cheney and
Rumsfeld the two primary figures who
were who were
creating the US response strategy to 911
and they wanted and this was not just a
Libby this was with many other prisoners
they wanted to get people that would say
that Saddam was working with al-qaeda or
that Saddam had weapons of mass
destruction and a lot of the torture
that took place early on including when
the US first went into Iraq and started
an extensive interrogation and detention
program a lot of the torture was aimed
at retro actively proving their claims
that Iraq had WMD or that there was some
sort of a connection to al-qaeda and I
think it was Alex who found who said
that you know al Libi at one point was
was so broken that he said he would just
tell them anything that they wanted to
hear because he he just saw it as I want
the torture to stop so if they're trying
to get me to say that Saddam has
something to do with al-qaeda I'll say
Saddam had something do with al-qaeda
and they actually used that intelligence
in our right and I mean you know Colin
Powell's speech when he finally went in
front of the United Nations was utterly
fraudulent and you know the question is
how much of it did Colin Powell actually
know was false I mean in terms of
developing his or assessing his own
culpability but certainly intelligence
was being cherry picked you know when
you have raw intelligence you it's not
been vetted it hasn't necessarily been
through the wringer with analysts whose
jaw whose entire careers are built on an
ability to analyze whether something is
legitimate on shaky ground part of it is
true what would started happening early
on is that Rumsfeld and Cheney and their
guys
Stephen cam bone on the defense side
Scooter Libby on the White House side
would go and sort of sift through raw
intelligence and these guys aren't
trained intelligence professionals and
they'll take little bits of something
that fit their political narrative and
then they'll build an alternative
intelligence dossier to the vetted CIA
presentations to the White House and
they'll say well the CIA is is is trying
to undermine this because they're
against military action so mr. president
we have this intelligence that is
actionable and indicates that we need to
move now on these targets or that we
have someone in custody and we need
authorization to escalate our
interrogation of him and that happened
that happened with hundreds of hundreds
of cases where these guys built
essentially a parallel intelligence
apparatus with non professional
intelligence figures but political
appointees plucking intelligence out so
that it would fit their case we've
talked about torture a little bit
the only real things that supporters of
President Obama will say is a important
difference between his record in the war
on terror and george w bush's is that we
no longer torture so do we no longer
torture no i mean i first of all you
know there's there's this psychologist
out in uh in the bay area named Jeffrey
K who's done some really good analysis
on the sort of shift from Bush to Obama
and looking at what the Obama policy is
and he's done really good reporting on
appendix M of the US Army Field Manual
which is now the standard and and has
made it I think a pretty credible
argument that there are tactics that are
still authorized that reasonable people
would probably consider to be torture
with the forms of sleep deprivation and
the use of dogs and the use of dietary
manipulation isolation lying to
prisoners telling them things have
happened to their family members I mean
that's a debate we should be having but
they but in the psychological community
and the the mental health professionals
that had worked as part of this program
there there's a school of them that say
that the even the minimum that Obama is
saying he's doing openly is torture but
but there's another layer to this that I
think is more important what I
discovered when I went to Mogadishu
Somalia is that under Obama the United
States is using a secret prison that is
buried in the basement of Somalia's
National Security Service which is
supported by the United States and there
are prisoners in there that have been
snatched from other countries and I told
the story of one guy in particular who
was taken on orders from the United
States from his home in Nairobi was
taken to Wilson Airport and then flown
to Somalia and put in this prison which
is an underground prison infested with
bedbugs
where no one has access to the Red Cross
in fact I was at a show with the Red
Cross and asked them about this they
said we've never heard of the prison and
I told him exactly where it was and we
tried to follow up and they haven't
responded to us about if they've
actually gone and looked at it but this
is under Obama we have people being held
in an underground prison in Somalia and
they're being interrogated by the CIA
and US military intelligence now
President Obama doesn't hold press
conferences talking about that
I believe him if he says that he's shut
down the CIA's black sites but what is
the real difference between having
someone put in a dungeon
in Somalia on your orders and then
interrogated by your intelligence
personnel and actually running the
facility in Thailand or Poland yourself
I mean that's that's how narrow the sort
of divide is between what the bush
people were doing and what Obama is
doing a lot of a lot of Obama's
counterterrorism policies are sort of
just rebranded versions of the bush
policy he's really trying to legitimize
it and I think he's done it successfully
for a majority of liberals they've sort
of taken the whole thing whole it's like
kool-aid drinking when it comes to
counterterrorism policy people believe
there's been this market shift from Bush
to Obama no way the core tenets of the
program live on under Obama in a way
that I think if McCain had been elected
liberals would be crying impeachment
over some of the stuff that Obama has
done Obama gave a big speech on May 23rd
it was supposed to be a big rethink on
the war on terror strategy and some
people who are colleagues of yours Jane
Meyer from The New Yorker especially
responded to it like hey this is a major
step in the right direction you seem to
be a bit more skeptical about no III
disagree I mean I mean Jane Mayer is one
of my journalistic heroes and I admire
her tremendously I don't agree that this
represented any kind of a major shift I
think what Obama I think Obama is
talking out of both sides of his mouth
on the one hand you know I think he's
sincere when he says that civilian
deaths are gonna haunt him until the day
he dies I don't I don't view him as some
kind of callous evil man plotting the
destruction of the world or celebrating
killing of you know civilians just
because they're Muslims or something and
I do think you have some sickos in
government that really particular after
9/11 wanted to just go and kill Muslims
and I don't think that Obama falls in
that category at all what I think is
happening though is that he's asserting
that the United States has right to
assassinate people in countries across
the globe if through some secret process
the executive branch determines they
pose a threat to US persons and and and
and and what I think is particularly
dangerous about it is that because he's
a popular Democratic president who's a
constitutional lawyer by trade and won
the Nobel Peace Prize a lot of liberals
have sort of checked their conscience at
the door of his presidency and and
they're sitting out you know looking in
any serious way at what the actual
policy is so on the one hand he's saying
we don't want to live in a state of
perpetual war
on the other hand in the week following
that speech he authorized a drone strike
in Pakistan and then authorized another
drone strike in Yemen and there may have
actually been two drone strikes in Yemen
where there's still lack of clarity on
what's going on in the east of Yemen
right now but there's very serious
fighting that the u.s. is involved with
in the east of Yemen so he's on the one
hand he's telegraphing instapass and
saying we don't want perpetual war on
the other hand he is the president who's
going to go down in history as having
created a streamlined system to
normalize assassination as a central
component of what they call u.s.
national security policy and and despite
all the rhetoric about wanting it to be
these actions to be conducted with with
great care and analysis the reality is
he's still continuing to use what are
called signature strikes sort of form of
pre-crime where in certain regions of
Yemen and Pakistan he and his advisers
have beamed targeted areas totally on
limits for any military age male
gathered with a group of military age
males we don't even have to know the
identities of the people that we are
targeting for assassination anymore they
just look from the sky as if to be of
the wrong age and crowded around the
wrong I mean up and frisked with drones
right exactly I mean I mean the way I
sort of see it is you know I think that
you know I don't think that they're
necessarily just looking for groups of
military-age males to bomb and then say
they're terrorists I do think that
there's some sort of some steps taken to
determine that someone in that group has
some connection to terrorism so I'll
give you an example that I think is
probably the most common way that this
happens you've got a guy that you're
that you're watching who attends a
certain mosque and then you start to
watch other guys that go into that
mosque and and in Pakistan or in Yemen
in certain places and and then then one
of the guys that you've been tracking
the coast of that mosque also goes to a
house that you you suspect may be a
place where their manufacturing IEDs and
now you've got a lock on that guy and
you have two places that he's been where
there's smoke around them and then he's
gathering with a group of other men and
you say well we're gonna just go ahead
and assume these guys must be up to no
good because this guy's been at that
mosque and he's been at this compound so
we're gonna assume that he's engaged in
terrorist activity and so he's then with
a group of other military age males
maybe they're sitting out having dinner
maybe they're at a funeral maybe they're
at a wedding and we say let's take this
opportunity because if that guy has so
much smoke around
these guys also must be up to no good we
don't know the identity of a single one
of these people we don't necessarily
have intelligence that they're involved
with any plotting against the United
States or any potential criminal
activity but we're going to prove it
preventively or preemptively
take them out so we kill them with a
drone strike and because they were in
this certain region and they're military
age males will posthumously declare that
they were militants or terrorists hence
the phrase suspected militants or
suspected terrorists that you Journal's
repeated all the time I'm having do it
having done it and I hate it every
single drone yemen's story starts a
suspected militant what is a suspected
militant you know I mean it's it's is
that now a death-penalty offense to be a
suspected militant we've got suspected
militants in the United States do we
have a sense of how many signatures or
strikes there have been no no and part
of it is because the the state of
oversight under the Obama administration
it's hard to believe I think at times
has been worse than it was when Bush and
Cheney were in office I mean I talked to
members of the Senate and House
intelligence committees who described to
me what this state of oversight is like
on the kill program and I think I mean
you may know this but I don't think most
Americans understand this which is
incredible certain senators not all
certain senators on the Intelligence
Committee are allowed to go to a secure
classified intelligence facility and
they had to fight to get the chance to
do this under Obama they go to a secured
classified intelligence facility they're
not allowed to bring in writing utensils
they can't bring in paper they can't
bring in anything with a battery and
they are allowed to look at certain
memos that the White House in secret has
cleared for them to look at even though
these are people by law who are a lot
who are not just allowed to but
responsible for overseeing covert
operations so they're given a redacted
set of documents basically from the
White House and they look at those and
then they're not allowed to tell anyone
what they've seen so so I'll sit in an
interview like in our film I'm
interviewing Ron Wyden and Ron Wyden
senator from Oregon has been tough on
this issue from Bush to Obama and has
fought the Obama White House and he said
to me it's as though there are two laws
in America there's one law that
reasonable people would read and come to
a conclusion of how to interpret that
law and most reasonable people would
interpret it roughly the same way and
then there's another law which is how
the White House has interpreted that
same law in secret and and and he said
the American people
if they could see the difference between
what they believe a law says and how
it's been interpreted by the president
and his advisers in secret as well can
you share the difference he said no I'm
not allowed to so I mean that's that's a
pretty chilling reality and we you know
we got a little flavor for that when
this Department of Justice white paper
was leaked and we saw him it that the
that these DOJ lawyers had redefined the
term imminent in such a way that no
reasonable person would agree with their
definition of imminent that having been
involved with past plots against the
United States means that you always
represent an imminent threat and that
and imminence doesn't have to be linked
to a temporal timing a sense of a threat
that you don't necessarily have to be
posing an imminent threat it's that your
very essence has become an imminent
threat and and and so therefore we're
engaged in this grotesque form of
pre-crime under mr. constitutional law
professor President Obama that if if if
McCain was asserting the right to bump
US citizens off without even charging
them with a crime when they're not on a
battlefield shooting at American troops
I think you would have seen a lot more
controversy about it I also think the
fact that the Americans that they killed
were Muslims and you know is is as part
of why people don't care I think if it
was John Smith that was being bumped off
in Yemen I think I think there would
have been more more outrage about it or
at least more questions being asked
Anwar al-aulaqi in yeah not the world's
most friendly fella by the time he was
bumped off he was beginning around 2009
he was making some pretty incendiary
comments about killing Americans you
argue pretty persuasively and he's a
thread throughout the book and it's it's
very fascinating sort of attempt at
humanizing that family and and
everything they went through there
hasn't been any persuasive links that he
was involved in terrorism period he was
a well what's your what is your argument
about him and Wright administration
claims
yeah about him you know Anwar Awlaki I'm
sure people what you know remember
seeing him on these YouTube videos and
there was a lot when the Christmas Day
bombing plot happened when this deranged
young Nigerian guy Omar Farouk
Abdulmutallab tried to blow up the plane
over Detroit there was this flurry of
media reports about Anwar Awlaki this
american-born cleric who was hiding in
Yemen or was in Yemen at the time being
involved with it and and you could go
online then and you could see videos of
Anwar a lot
in a camouflage jacket in front of a
black flag calling for armed jihad
against the United States calling on
young Muslims to conduct attacks in the
United States or in other countries
where they live or to come and join the
Mujahideen in Yemen or Somalia or
Afghanistan and fight against the United
States and he he was a guy that that was
openly calling for attacks against the
United States he wasn't always that man
and what I tried to explore in the book
and in the film is how does someone end
up on a YouTube video like that and and
end up on the u.s. kill list being the
first American citizen that we know to
be targeted for assassination under
President Obama
well Anwar Awlaki was a guy who who grew
up in the United States for the first
part of his life then went back to Yemen
with his father who was a government
minister and was a Fulbright Scholar
actually and his parents are I know them
very well they are not their son I mean
they're very upstanding people and who
actually have quite serious admiration
for the United States it was why they
wanted to come here in the first place
and and but but Anwar Awlaki their
eldest son was a guy who first was
politicized by the Gulf War in 91 when
he was a college student in Colorado he
was not a particularly religious guy but
became religious after the Gulf War and
and and his life took a different
direction he ended up becoming an imam
on 9/11 he was the Imam at a large
mosque in Falls Church Virginia the dar
al Hydra religious center and was
actually on TV a lot he was profiled by
the Washington Post for a piece about
Ramadan he was on the news hour with Jim
Lehrer talking to moderate Muslim
because he was condemning 9/11 attacks
and saying that al Qaeda had perverted
Islam and at the same time he was saying
you know look there shouldn't be a war
against Islam and Muslims shouldn't be
targeted by the FBI in the way that our
communities are being targeted and he
was dealing with hate crimes that were
being committed against Muslims and
attacks on Muslim businesses and you
know to make a long story short he ends
up deciding he's gonna leave the United
States he's being interrogated
repeatedly in private by the FBI the FBI
was trying to flip him to be you haven't
be an informant it's quite possible that
at a point in his life he actually was
working with the FBI I mean I to me it's
a very gray area he was such an accepted
member of American society after 9/11
that he was invited to a luncheon at the
Pentagon and actually gave a lecture at
the Pentagon and to give you a sense of
how bad their intelligence was they
served a bacon sandwich at the luncheon
Occulus and no WMDs and
quite no not to serve the bacon sandwich
that Imam was coming to speak about the
state of Islam in the world
but as the war spread and we go to Iraq
happening in Abu Ghraib and then
Guantanamo is sort of festering on he
starts to become radicalized and ends up
recording sermons he already was sort of
his CDs were popular around the world
but his sermons used to be of a
theological nature now they become much
more sharp political condemnation of the
United States he hasn't crossed a line
yet you know but he's starting to flirt
with the idea that the you know that
people should fight against the United
States his sermons start popping up and
this is in like 2005-2006 start popping
up in terror investigations in Canada
Britain the United States meaning that
that young people plots that are busted
up they're finding al lackeys CDs on
these things so in the in 2006 Awlaki is
is in Yemen attending a mosque there and
going to some classes and he's arrested
on on charges that he's intervened in a
tribal dispute and he believed very
firmly that the United States had put
him in prison so he spends 18 months in
a Yemeni prison 17 of them in solitary
confinement what I discovered in my
reporting is that it was John Negroponte
a who was the Director of National
Intelligence at the time who told the
Yemeni government that the u.s. wanted a
lock he put in prison for four or five
years so that young Muslims would forget
about him
John Negroponte II who was a character
in Iran right and knows a lot about
dirty wars I mean he was in in Honduras
you know as one of the main people
helping to fuel the Contra war in nearby
Nicaragua and would write these reports
from Honduras that would make you know
the the hunter there seemed like you
know some kind of a Swiss human rights
committee instead of being murderous
thugs and and you know negroponte a then
under Bush becomes the first head of you
know this director of national
intelligence and and tells the Yemenis
to put one of his own citizens Anwar
Awlaki was an American in this prison so
he's held in this prison for four it was
supposed to be for four or five years
tremendous pressure on the dictator of
Yemen internally to release Anwar Awlaki
so he ends up getting sprung and comes
out of prison a totally changed man
creates a blog and the Internet becomes
his mosque and he starts really crossing
a line and saying you know that the US
should be fought and he's sort of
painting a world where the United States
and Israel are in a war against Islam
and he said
operating victories of any Islamic
movement around the world and answering
questions from people about is suicide
bombing acceptable under the teachings
of the Quran and and and and the u.s. is
putting all this pressure on the Yemeni
government to rehearse on we're all
lucky and the intelligence services are
constantly surveilling the home
so while Lockheed decides to leave sama
the capital of Yemen and he goes to
their family's tribal area in the south
of Yemen this place called Chev WA and
and eventually the head of Yemeni
intelligence comes to his father who's
this upstanding guy and says look if you
don't get Anwar to go back into the
prison the Americans were gonna kill him
with a drone this is before the
underwear bomb plot this is before any
allegation has been made that al lackeys
involved with terror plots it was simply
his speech that the United States was
trying to stop I haven't seen anyone
make an allegation that he was involved
with a terror plot prior to this what
seals his fate though is two things one
Major Nidal Hasan this AR it was an Army
psychiatrist opens fire at Fort Hood
Texas on his fellow soldiers and kills
13 of them in November of 2009 and
wounds scores of others and has
paralyzed himself in the operation and
it emerges that Al Lockheed had been an
email touch with him
al walk he was an email touch with
hundreds of people around the world and
then when in US intelligence
investigated it they said that there was
no no evidence to suggest that Allah key
was involved at that plot the story
persists to this day in fact you can go
online and read stories where people are
saying that he was behind it that he
directed it I haven't seen any evidence
to suggest that he was I don't know I
maybe I have maybe there's stuff I
haven't seen but you law enforcement and
intelligence the only on record
statements about him are that they
didn't see anything in those emails to
indicate he had something to do with it
but the reason I'm going to legs to tell
you this is because the next day Allah
keep us a blog post that says in the
Dallas on was a hero and says that we
need more Nidal Hasan's and that Muslims
in the military should should kill non
Muslim soldiers to prevent them from
committing war crimes in Afghanistan or
Iraq then you have the underwear bomb
plot which I'll lucky also praised and
then it emerges that al lucky had met
with Umar Farouk Abdulmutallab this
young Nigerian guy Allah he said that he
didn't have anything to do with the plot
but that he supported it and and that
that put him on the kill list so January
2010 wash
and post reveals for the first time that
Anwar Awlaki and three other Americans
are on the US kill list and from that
moment until September of 2011 al Lackey
was underground and on the run and being
hunted by the US and there were upwards
of a dozen drone strikes aimed at trying
to kill him which killed other people or
fell harmlessly or both that's
interesting there there was a strike one
of the early strikes against Anwar
al-awlaki
at the end of 2009 ended up killing a
number of innocent innocent people in
one of the other strikes that there were
these two guys who were affiliated in
some way with al-qaeda that had come to
bail a lockheed out and they ended up
getting killed and a locky escaped so
III don't know the answer to your
question and I I don't I mean I try to
be very careful in talking about when
civilians were killed and when they
weren't what I do know is that the first
track President Obama authorized against
Yemen on December 17th 2009 was not a
drone strike it was a cruise missile
attack on what they believed was an al
Qaeda training camp and they ended up
hitting a Bedouin village and killing 46
people 14 women and 21 children and you
know I went to Abhiyan province where
this missile strike happened and we
videotaped the cruise missile parts very
clearly showing that it was a u.s.
attack and we the u.s. use cluster bombs
on this village which are like flying
land mines that most countries around
the world consider them banned under
international law but the u.s. doesn't
recognize certain conventions so the US
hasn't signed on to that Convention
continues to use these flying landmines
basically and shredded these people in
the pursuit of one guy that they claimed
was an al Qaeda figure and you know it's
unclear that that guy even had any
operational role in it I mean part of
the problem here is that when you're
engaged in pre-crime you no longer have
the burden of actually proving that the
people you call enemies are enemies
and that's the world we live in right
now so many we don't even know how many
people we've killed I don't know if
innocent people were killed in the
pursuit of Anwar Awlaki I don't know
that Anwar al-awlaki was guilty of
anything that he was charged with
because he wasn't actually charged with
a crime but I'm willing to concede for
the sake of argument on a moral or legal
level that Anwar al-awlaki is guilty of
every single thing that the
administration has leaked about him or
that the president said in his speech
that he was actively involved with the
Christmas
they plot that he was plotting to poison
water supplies in the United States that
he spent every waking moment of his life
thinking up plots or ways to kill
Americans the question for me becomes
then how do we as a society respond to
one of the most reprehensible of our
citizens do we just sentence them to
death without some kind of a process
this isn't a guy who has a sniper rifle
pointed at a crowd full of people this
is a guy in the middle of nowheres Ville
Yemen who I believe we probably could
have hunted down and found and they
haven't isolated in this house I think
we probably could have apprehended him
so for me the question is why was his
death so important that we didn't even
bother seeking an indictment against him
President Obama is the one who said that
if he had his choice chance or a choice
he would have prosecuted Anwar Awlaki
really then why didn't you ever seek an
indictment against him it's incredible
if you're hunting the guy for let's say
two full years why why at some point in
that didn't you say here's the charge
against him we want him extradited and
if you don't extradite in the United
States is gonna take unilateral action
against you Osama bin Laden was indicted
the guys who were involved blowing up
the embassies in 98 were indicted we
have terrorists that have been put
through our system in this country Nidal
Hasan who killed 13 US soldiers he's
getting a trial John Walker Lindh who
took up arms against the United States
was given access to the civilian justice
system was when do we just start
sentencing people to death without
charging them with crimes I mean that to
me is the issue about Al Lackey he said
things I find reprehensible and I think
he probably was involved with you know
some nefarious thinking against the
United States was he actually an
operational member of al-qaeda I don't
know I'd like to see that evidence not
saying he wasn't Obama intervened
personally to keep him any journalists
in jail yeah this to me is shameful I
book on my my book why the front end of
my book I say that you know the book is
dedicated to journalists who are
imprisoned for for doing their jobs and
those who die in pursuit of the truth
and then the last line of my book is
that this Yemeni journalist Abdulelah
Haider Shia is in prison in part because
of the intervention of President Obama
and he should be set free the short
story version of the story is that after
Obama started authorizing the bombing of
Yemen in December of oh nine the US had
engaged in this conspiracy with the
Yemeni government to cover-up the u.s.
role and for Yemen to take
responsibility or credit for the attacks
that the United States was going to
start conducting we know that because of
the WikiLeaks cables the meetings
between General Petraeus who was at the
time was
CENTCOM commander and the Yemeni
president so this first strike happens
that Obama's authorized on Yemen the
Yemeni government puts out a press
release saying that Yemen air forces
have attacked this al Qaeda base and
killed 34 terrorists and then the u.s.
sends congratulations to Yemen but you
ever had nothing to do with it it was
all the US cruise missile attack the
first person to go and report on the
fact that there were these US munitions
used that Yemen doesn't possess was this
guy Abdulelah Haider Shia who was a
journalist that was doing very serious
reporting on the rise of al-qaeda in
Yemen and was interviewing al Qaeda
leaders and doing actually quite
critical interviews with al Qaeda people
far more critical than anything we see
in the White House press corps of the
President of the United States so this
guy is interviewing al Qaeda leaders
he's exposed a u.s. missile attack soon
after that he gets abducted by Yemen's
US backed intelligence service taken to
a an interrogation center and beaten and
told that if you don't stop talking
about the American bombing in Yemen
we're gonna put you back in here for
good and so he immediately leaves that
first abduction goes on al Jazeera and
says I've been snatched and and I'm
gonna you know and and it's because they
want me to stop talking about the fact
that America is now bombing Yemen and
I'm going to continue to report on this
and he did he continued to report on it
and he interviewed Anwar Awlaki at a
time when the CIA apparently couldn't
find him and and because of his
interviews with Al Lackey we know that
al lockheed praised the the underwear
bomber and he had he did a very I
encourage people to look at it he did a
very critical interview with the lucky
where he's saying why is it that you're
praising and attempted down an airliner
full of civilians how can you say that's
a military target let me keep imagine
being that journalist sitting here with
this guy and you're you're not just
lobbing softballs at him you're asking
real questions so this is why I'm so
outraged about this so he's doing all
this reporting he provided photographs
to human rights organizations of the
munitions that definitively proved after
they were analyzed by munitions experts
that they the only party that could have
conducted these bombings was the United
States so now the world knows the United
States is conducting a bombing campaign
in Yemen eventually Abdullah Haider Shia
is taken in a night raid on his home
disappears for 34 days and then he is
hauled into a special tribunal that has
been set up by the dictator of the
to prosecute journalists for crimes
against the state and he's brought into
in a cage and they charged him with
being an al Qaeda facilitator and they
present all this trumped-up evidence
against him they fabricate documents
saying he's involved with all these
plots every major human rights and media
freedom organization in the world
condemned his trial and condemned the
tribunal that he was being prosecuted in
in fact he refused even put on a defense
because I'm not gonna recognize the
court and you know there's this video of
him in the cage saying that the only
reason I'm here is because I exposed the
cruise missile attacks that the United
States did against Yemen and that this
is what happens when you do real
journalism in Yemen and you're not a
sycophant for their regime so they
sentence him to five years in prison
huge outcry in Yemen and outside of
Yemen from the human rights and media
community media freedom community not
not other journalists all this pressure
and then the dictator of Yemen decides
well I'm gonna release Abdullah oh hi -
I have an issue a pardon not say that
he's not guilty but I'm gonna pardon him
over his crimes and the it leaks in the
Yemeni press that the dictator of
Yemen's gonna pardon Abdullah Haider
Shia that day he gets a phone call from
the White House not from some
undersecretary or you know some
assistant to the President President
Obama personally calls him and says that
the United States is deeply concerned
about reports that you're going to
release of the Lella Haider Shia the
pardon is then ripped up and he remains
in prison to this moment when I'm
talking to you the White House just in
the first few days of June told my
colleague Ryan grim at the Huffington
Post that it remains the White House's
position that he's dangerous and should
be kept in prison Wow so this is a we're
in an environment where The Associated
Press had its phone records seized not
just on one or two reporters but on you
know dozens of phone lines where there
were these the attempt to imply criminal
conduct was committed on the part of
James Rosen this Fox News journalist you
have whistleblowers that are being
targeted by this White House in record
numbers and you have the President of
the United States constitutional law
professor Nobel Peace Prize winner
keeping a respected Yemeni journalist in
prison seemingly because he had that he
committed the crime of doing actual
journalism and and and and and the thing
to me that sort of outrageous you know
outrage upon outrage is that none of the
big US media outlets that he did work
for that were happy to run his content
the Washington Post
ABC News NBC News none of them have said
a thing about his case that's shameful
you know III never worked with him at
all but I I I try to bring him up every
day of my life because I there's
something so fundamentally rotten when
when the most powerful man in the world
can keep a journalist in Yemen in prison
without ever having to present a piece
of evidence that he was involved with
anything except responsible journalism
Church Commission kind of is an
interesting root of a lot of things it's
the root of the cheney rumsfeld theory
of executive power which then sort of
swings the pendulum back over here
beginning after 9/11 do you think do you
see any kind of political winds that
suggest maybe the pendulum can start
swinging back here or have the sort of
locked-in gains from Obama over Bush
kind of created a system that can't even
come back this way there any any reason
to hope politically or societally that
we can change the conversation I think
the Obama presidency has been
devastating for the cause of
accountability or trying to rein in a
kind of out-of-control counterterrorism
or what's called the counterterrorism
machine I actually think we're gonna
inspire more acts of terrorism than we
are preventing them through our policies
it would require an entirely different
set of lawmakers you know if you look at
the recent hearings where they were
discussing drones or discussing targeted
killing you know you have al franken
returning to just being a comedian
instead of a lawmaker and and getting
into this whole thing about how we need
a we need a drone court where then you
know judges apparently are gonna be what
Al Franken wants parents for judges to
then review targets and decide when it's
legal it will still be in secret but you
take it out of one branch of government
and put it into the other branch
government I mean that's the that's the
extent of the debate the debate we need
to be having is are we creating more new
enemies than we are killing terrorists
with our policy who have we actually
killed do an assessment of that who are
we in bed with politically around the
world these dictatorships that we prop
up unsavory security forces that were
supporting you know drones are just one
part of this I'm actually I have a much
deeper concern about the Obama
administration's support for Human
Rights abusing military forces around
the world I think that's gonna
back to hit us to when we're funding and
beefing up militaries in Africa and the
Arabian Peninsula in the name of
fighting terrorism those forces can
easily be used for domestic repression
of their own citizens and I mean I
there's going to be blowback from all of
this so you're asking question about
lawmakers I mean we would need a totally
different set of people there that
actually cared about these issues and
that's true on a variety of issues it's
true about our civil liberties at home
it's true about media freedoms I mean
the fact that Rand Paul was the was the
guy who stood up and I supported him in
doing it who stood up and filibustered
John Brennan's nomination says a lot
about where we are where are all these
serious Democrats you know who believe
in civil liberties where are the people
that originally were against John
Brennan because of his statements on
torture you know they're nowhere so I
give you no I don't agree with Rand Paul
on much in the world but I give him a
lot of credit for having the spine to
stand up and say you know for one day we
are going to stop business as usual and
he read into the record serious
reporting for the first time ever said
the names of US citizens who'd been
killed in operations authorized by
President Obama but the fact that it's
someone like him doing it instead of you
know Democrats who spent so much time
under the Bush era condemning these very
same things says a lot about how
bankrupt Congress is on this and other
issues well I'm not sure II know it's
vague I will close up the name of the
book and the documentary is dirty Wars
Jeremy Scahill has been our guest for
recent TV I'm Matt well thank you